[Musica]
my people ai ragazzi questo video che
diciamo un maschio alto non dovrebbe mai
fare ma va ai ragazzi allora gioco da
animal crossing da wired rimini dal 1600
anni fa quando è uscito questo new
crossing ho detto ci devo assolutamente
giocare quello che state vedendo è il
mio villaggio faccio una piccola
premessa golosa anche prima la premessa
è che non gioco ad animal crossing da
due mesi due mesi perché ci ho giocato
un sacco nel periodo di quarantena ma
tantissimo però poi l'ho abbandonato
perché sono tornato a milano e ho
iniziato a fare vino insomma non c'è più
giocato vedete un po la mia città piena
di erbacce cose del genere sono un
fenomeno bollettino perché effettiva
cuoce volvolo benissimo la prima volta
che vedo volvolo questo qua è a e
alessandro orlando e questa diventi
quadri
no ragazzi e incredibile ti vendi quali
per le prove che ti vede un sacco di
quadri falsi
cioè non ti vende il mario schifano
dipende delle robe or il quadro buffo va
bene voglio e stavo dicendo quindi la
mia città è piena di erbacce non lo più
non l'ho più tanto guardata sono sincero
perché appunto ho giocato ad altra roba
ma nonostante questo ho giocato
abbastanza potrebbero far vedere e non
passare come l'ultimo che ha giocato
animal crossing nel mondo quindi può
essere anche un video di un video carino
se vi faccio vedere che cosa fate me lo
spiego nel frattempo prendiamo sto pesce
mi sembra abbastanza grosso e non
fraintendete il linguaggio partiamo
dalla mia umilissima dimora che poi vi
farò vedere per bene perché adesso
partiamo dall'esterno
questa è casa mia ho fatto una
recinzione un po strano effettivamente
perché un po piccola però insomma c'è il
sushi
questo l'ho preso all'evento di pasqua
che era ad aprile
ce l'ha ma cacce uno schifo sui miei
fiori dopodiché ragazzi se seguiamo il
vialetto proseguiamo arriviamo alle
cascate di entrata per entrare nel mio
nel mio villaggio si possono queste
cascate meravigliose che ho ricoperto
anche di fantastici fiori che ho
scoperto che non appassiscono perché non
vi è nato da due mesi
fantastico poi si va verso destra
volendo e c'è la parte dove ho messo
dopo piantati bambù ibamboo sono molto
utili perché li puoi vendere un sacco di
soldi e ci fai anche un sacco di oggetti
carini andando verso destra ancora ho
piazzato una lapide ma solo fatto in
modo facoltativo perché stavo finendo
un'altra parte della città per la dovrò
farlo piazza da lì poi non ho più
continuate una sega comunque 9 vedete un
sacco di armarci anche in giro per lo
stesso motivo
ma ritorniamo sulla strada di prima
quindi tornando dalle cascate se si
prosegue dritto
c'è un mini vialetto e si arriva al
municipio disimpegno un po grosso
addietro la dietro il municipio lo
vedete che allora questa è la cosa che
ha sempre dato fastidio la faccio notare
dove rete che non è perfettamente
allineato no il municipio con la cosa
dietro ecco questo perché quando lo
arredato tutto non aveva ancora che cosa
per modificare il terreno e quindi
vedete che asimmetrico da un fastidio
allucinante proprio ci potevo fare
niente
davanti abbiamo il lago gigantesco che
questo qua che tra l'altro fatto anche
questa cosa simpatica e qui ci volevo
mettere qualcosa probabimente la lapide
adesso non mi ricordo però non non ce
l'ho più o meno sapevo perché sono pigro
quindi niente però ho fatto tutto al
grosso quindi tutto uniformato per bene
tutto il tutto il villaggio dei ragazzi
proseguendo se si va dritto c'è allora
il museo la mia sinistra che poi vedremo
qua ecco qua avevo pecora qua che avevo
messo la figlia perché ne ho trovate due
quest'ora cimitero fatto anche un
cimitero in animal crossing fantastico
c'è un solo una lapide ma gli obiettivo
da quello di averne tante
voglio un sacco di morti nel mio
villaggio e dopodiché c'è una scalinata
che proseguendo verso l'alto ti porta
alla vista e
ma che avrei dovuto metterci una
panchina però non non ero arrivato a
prenderla comunque vedete in testa c'è
già tutto il grosso e fa perché fare
questa roba di colline su colline con le
scale quale che ci ho messo un sacco di
tempo sembra una cazzata ma ci si mette
veramente un sacco comunque proseguiamo
avanti se si fa lo slalom tra i vari
alberi si arriva al giardino degli
aranci che è molto carino e ci sono solo
questo e la via degli aranci perché
giardini sono solo 5 aranci però tutti
quelli che vedete che ho nell'inventario
data perché volevo farne un altro di
giardino semplicemente ho smesso di
giocare quindi non l'ho fatto questo
punto è quadrato ci ricongiunge alla mia
casa quindi questo posso quasi tra
esattamente sopra casa mia e io ho fatto
vedere più o meno tutta la parte a
destra del del villaggio ma passiamo a
quella di sotto a sinistra questo
ragazzi e il ponte che costa di più di
tutti al ponte giapponese costa un sacco
di soldi è una volta passati co sinistra
allora adesso vi spiego perché a vedersi
fa un po cagare ma vi spiego cosa volevo
fare la verità ragazzi che questo posto
che state vedendo doveva essere sarebbe
dovuto essere il villa c'è il punto dove
dove raggruppare tutte le case se con
date in basso a destra c'è tutto il mio
villaggio non vedete le case in giallo
sono quelle sparse per per il villaggio
tutte le case a destra ok tranne la mia
che quella rosa tutte le case a destra
avrei dovuto posizionarli in questo in
questo punto fa per averle tutte vicine
quindi avrei avuto casa mia che la mega
villa di fianco lì e poi qua tutte le
altre case
vicine tutti insieme perché tutta
l'altra parte del villaggio dovrebbe
essere adibita a spazi esterni carini
parchi cosa e quindi tutte le case
dovevano essere vicine ma posso messo di
giocare and hers mai vero amazing
and if you going ai workshop di chi c'è
un insetto per terra che schifo è che
cacchio pensavo bravo secondo me solo
prezzi ma come non era mai capitato e
venisse ti in casa secondo lo abbiamo
col retino mi dava me lo prendeva
proprio comunque ragazzi allora casa mia
era e stavo scherzando data è tutta in
work in progress perché io di casa mia
vedete che ho messe in giro le cose che
ho trovato cioè non ho cercato di fare
stanza per stanza ok perché non ci ho
giocato abbastanza ad avere tutti sti
oggetti ma sono particolarmente
orgoglioso della parte sinistra che
quella che state per vedere in 3 2 1 le
cure
una volta arrivati qua dentro se si
spegne la luce che non mi dico non si
spegne la luce spegnerà ecco così
perfetto c'è una giusta atmosfera perché
hai le terme c'è in casa mia c'è la
spagna questa è stata l'unica parte
della casa che ho saputo arredare in
modo completo come se fossero ce l'ho
fatta prova terme il resto della casa
invece è un'accozzaglia di oggetti che
ho messo uno sopra l'altro in base a
quelli che riuscivo a trovare
posizionare quindi non è particolarmente
ma basta né particolarmente riuscito
anche a far la cucina perché non
riuscivo a trovare gli oggetti da
costruire però che ti devo dire convivo
con gli insetti
mi sono anche fatto l'angolo youtuber
che gocciola segnerà che lava nella
sedia da ufficio
la scrivania e ciò anche le luci di
posizione che sono le stesse che sto
usando in questo momento incredibile mi
manca solo il computer in compenso cioè
i compiti in confusione ragazzi abbiamo
la stanza a destra che è la più sfoglia
di tutte quante però vi spiego cosa
volevo fare
stavo cercando di fare una stanza a mo
di horror
cioè io sto cercando mettere le cose per
crearla proprio a livello spettrale e
quindi
avete un giradischi a teschio questo che
lo specchio del demonio ultimo ragazzi
ma non meno importante il piano di sopra
perché stavo facendo anche quello
anche questa abbastanza spoglio ma
l'idea di fare musica c'era però vedo
che ci sono solo due chitarre e e g
il col de police quindi ragazzoni questa
era la mia è la mia partita di animal
crossing sono il mio villaggio di fatto
un po vedere tutto come stavo ancora
lavorando stavo facendo cose volo ancora
cambiare tanto diciamo che mi sa che mi
sarebbero servite un'altra ventina di
ore di gioco per fare tutto come dico io
come se avete ragazzi suoi video è
cresciuto lasciato argomento è un bel
like sono fatti di sapere se il mio
villaggio di piace per quanto non sia
per niente finito però vi ho fatto
vedervi o vi ho raccontato un po come
sarebbe dovuto diventare eravamo sulla
sfera ma all 80 90 per cento comunque
devo solo mettere le cose nuove finire
un paio di rilievi
ditemi se vi fa piacere se vi fa cagare
non siete più mi amici però ciao
[Musica]